no matter how long you have lived in the
desert temperatures like we saw today
are never easy to take
according to the national weather
service extreme heat is on
average the number one weather-related
killer in the united states
sasha loftis joins us more on what
really can be dangerous conditions
brian it is 11 o'clock at night and it
is still roasting out there now this
thermometer
stops reading at 110 degrees if you take
the temperature of this pavement
it is clearly a lot hotter than that the
local experts we spoke with today say
it's really important to remember the
brutal conditions
temperatures like this can bring it's
very hard to handle
whether you're a native los vegan or
just moved to the mojave desert
i mean he's brutal the extreme heat
we've seen this summer
is downright ruthless what we're really
focused on
is this dangerous heat wave joshua
merrill is one of many vendors who
braved
114 degrees at the las vegas farmers
market in the west valley wednesday
literally will dictate how well the day
will be just by off the forecast so
those weeks that's 115 like this week we
know okay sales aren't going to be as
good as they will be he says
weather like this can really hurt his
livelihood
ruin products and cause health concerns
according to clark county coroner
melanie rouse 124 people died during
local heat waves in 2020
so far this year 12 people have lost
their lives
she says it's important to take these
conditions seriously
and help those who aren't used to it
it's about communicating that to the
visitors in our community
that may not be familiar with how hot
that really is
so as the temps in the one teens
continue
merrill urges others to understand the
real danger
they bring the heat it's weather
conditions affect a lot of people
and do their best to stay safe as we
ride out the rest of the season
stay hydrated and stay in
now again this thermometer stops working
at 110 degrees you can see it's not even
registering
the temperature of the pavement right
now which means it's at least
that hot on the ground the clark county
coroner says
it really is important to have water
stations out for people
who aren't used to this kind of heat or
people who are stuck out in the heat
during the hottest times a day just
again
preparation is really important when it
comes to extreme heat here in las vegas
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now